un jeu de 52 cartes soigneusement
mélanger le défi de ce jeune suédois
par les mémoriser dans l'ordre en un
minimum de temps
il s'appelle marvin est à seulement 21
ans
ce génie de la mémoire est capable
d'exploits incroyable 33 secondes et
trois centièmes pour retenir un paquet
entier
est ce possible
marvin doit maintenant mettre ses
neurones en action sous l'oeil des juges
pour reconstituer la suite de cartes
[Musique]
ne reste plus qu'à comparer sa
combinaison avec le paquet témoins pour
connaître le verdict
oh
[Musique]
zéro faute c'est le genre de prouesses
exceptionnelles qui ont fait de marvin
une star planétaire pour mieux faire
mieux y avait bien mieux le cerveau n'a
pas de limites
sinon c'est à toi de fixer des limites
le cerveau n'a pas de limites comme lui
ils sont 275 a tenté de repousser les
limites du cerveau humain en participant
au championnat du monde de la mémoire
des candidats de 27 pays différents
réunis en chine pour trois jours de
compétition les plus jeunes n'ont que 8
ans soyez brillant aujourd'hui
[Musique]
vous êtes les guerriers de l'esprit au
milieu de cette concentration de matière
grise unique au monde
joël 62 ans le seul candidat français il
s'est qualifié grâce à un bon score lors
d'un championnat européen
aujourd'hui il va devoir mémoriser des
centaines de photos d'identité en
quelques minutes
retenir des suites de milliers de
chiffres ou encore apprendre par coeur
des dizaines de paquets de cartes
tu prends du plaisir ici la députée ici
oui je crois que j'irai aussi beaucoup
de mal de tête parce qu'ils étaient
prêts qu'ils m'ont une grande
concentration et au bout d'une heure ou
deux heures s'est tendu tout coeur il
faut éviter sur la moindre erreur
joël pourra-t-il battre marvin le jeune
prodige suédois et remporté le premier
prix un chèque de trente mille euros
quels sont les secrets de ces athlètes
de l'intelligence
aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître vous allez découvrir que nous
possédons tous un cerveau capable comme
de réaliser des miracles
[Musique]
c'est à marseille où il habite que joël
a préparé depuis plus d'un an les
championnats du monde de la mémoire
nous le retrouvons quelques jours avant
son départ pour la chine en pleine
révision ce matin contrairement aux
apparences
joël ne se balade pas sur le vieux port
il s'exerce à retenir un maximum de
plaques d'immatriculation de bateaux 30
82 44 34 81 92
48 10 24
en me concentrant bien étant calme je
pense que je dois être capable d'en
obtenir deux sens pourtant ce formateur
de profession ne possède pas un qi hors
norme
sa mémoire d'éléphant c'est par passion
qu'il l'a développée grâce à certaines
techniques apprises dans des manuels
comme celui ci c'est un livre que j'ai
trouvé sûrement par hasard et se livrer
en effet expliquent bien toutes les
principales techniques de mémorisation
comment retenir un texte que le fait de
plus en apprend plus on développe notre
capacité de mémorisation comment il faut
être tout à fait curieux du river une
cinquantaine de livres sur la mémoire la
rambla la mémoire intelligente
c'est sur la base de ces méthodes que
joël s'entraîne depuis plus de quatre
ans à booster ses neurones logiciels erp
par exemple pour mémoriser une suite de
chiffres en un temps record
l'une des techniques consiste à isoler
les chiffres par groupes de trois chaque
nombre correspond à un mode est terminée
et a pris l avance il suffit de
remplacer chaque groupe de chiffres par
le mot correspondants et de s'inventer
une histoire avec ses mots
un jeu d'enfant sauf qu'à six mille
kilomètres de marseille en chine
dans quelques jours ce ne sont pas
quelques chiffres mais des milliers que
joël va devoir retenir il faudra
redoubler d'imagination pour s'inventer
un roman à chaque épreuve
[Musique]
nous sommes à chengdu une ville
industrielle en plein coeur de la chine
c'est ici dans le centre de conférence
que va se dérouler la 24e édition de la
compétition pendant trois jours ce matin
joël un petit peu l'impression de
retourner sur les bancs de l'école
en découvrant ses concurrents j'ai
présenté à l'examen
d'autant plus qu'il y à 180 chinois et
donc il ya beaucoup d'enfants c'est
comme une rentrée des classes
l'équipe chinoise et la plus redoutée
des adolescents mais aussi des bambins
surdoué d'une dizaine d'années encadrés
par des coachs aux méthodes
révolutionnaires
il ya deux ans je les repérer car il est
vraiment passionné un mois seulement
après avoir appris la méthode de
mémorisation il a réussi à réciter très
couramment deux des poèmes
particulièrement difficile à mémoriser
je trouve ça très amusant d'être là je
rencontre des gens intéressants
les entraînements c'est sympa mais la
compétition c'est mieux
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé de
participer à ce championnat
quitte à aller bon courage
au programme du jour une épreuve qui va
demander une concentration sur humaine à
joël aux jeunes champions chinois mais
également à marvin le génie suédois qui
se met toujours debout pour se
concentrer
il s'agit de retenir par coeur et dans
l'ordre
cette liste de chiffres distribué par
les juges une torture pour le cerveau
imaginé par cet homme tony bizane auteur
de plusieurs ouvrages sur la mémoire
c'est lui qui a créé cette compétition
c'est une des épreuves de nombres pas de
cravate c'est chez nous en sommes là il
y a cinq mille chine
les gens se disent c'est impossible à
personne ne peut retenir
en vérité le cerveau humain qu'un de les
mémoriser
ils n'ont qu'une heure pour mémoriser
les 5000 chiffres
une opération facile pour nos
ordinateurs mais très éprouvante pour le
cerveau à chacun sa technique pour se
concentrer
mais pour tous le même but regrouper les
chiffres les transformer en mots et se
fabriquer sa petite histoire
[Musique]
ensuite les candidats ont un quart
d'heure pour restituer les chiffres dans
un tableau
marvin est l'un des premiers à sortir
attendu par ses parents qui l'ont
accompagné en chine pour cette épreuve
le fils prodige s'est inventé un
scénario digne d'une production
hollywoodienne habana j'ai vu une banane
à un pokémon et comment on dit déjà un
pas rapide mais ça fait un scénario où
le pokémon tient un parapluie car il
peut des bananes un film à deux oscars
joël lui est déçu il n'a pu restituer
qu'une quarantaine de chiffres et son
scénario ressemblait plus à une série
télé bien française du vin qui seront
vers sur un costume et qui tombe
également sur la nuque de jacques delors
jacques delors c'était pour moi le
numéro 97 par exemple on a intérêt à
prendre de l'aspirine
c'est une épreuve redoutable redoutait
dans le sens qu'il faut surtout surtout
ne pas s'être trompé de chiffres dans la
reconstitution
l'épreuve est remportée par marvin va
l'onu à l'annoncé des résultats
marvin a réussi l'impensable il a
mémorisé parker 2665 chiffres
un nouveau record du monde qui fait la
fierté de toute la famille
maintenant il est premier au classement
vous êtes fier de lui on est vraiment
très fier de lui vraiment très fier
c
vous savez il est normal à la maison
parfois il perd ses affaires mais c'est
vrai que quand ils jouent aux cartes
avec ses frères et soeurs c'est ce
qu'ils ont dans les mains c'est amusant
il connaît toujours d'avant ce qu'ils
vont jouer en plus des méthodes apprises
dans les livres cet étudiant en médecine
un petit secret bien à lui pour rester
au top niveau
vous allez où maintenant au gymnase pour
faire de l'exercice physique avant et
après chaque épreuve
direction la salle de sport pour faire
travailler ses muscles
selon lui c'est un moyen infaillible de
booster l'oxygénation du cerveau et donc
de doper ses neurones
je mange un minimum
chikane parce que la digestion ça tombe
de l'oxygène au cerveau ça surtout je
m'entraîne juste avant les épreuves
ou alors je vais faire un footing parce
que ça te fait une décharge d'énergie
dans le cerveau situe pour juste avant
l'épreuve
c'est une mise en condition bien
différente que joël a choisi pour les
épreuves suivantes classé dans les
derniers après cette première journée il
a décidé de se requinquer effet vous
mettez ce doigt ici et l'autre là en
découvrant les spécialités locales avec
un candidat danois
il va tenter de cuisine est une jeune
concurrente chinoise et son entraîneur
de foot in the secret of them the
memories of fate changement est fou de
ses couettes un big même ri avec ce
réalisation de percer le secret des
athlètes chinois de mémoire sur meu les
concurrencer il faut bien qu'on perd ses
secrets si demain on a une progression
très nette
ces lieux soja et célia puisqu'on
si joël ne trouve pas rapidement la
solution cette épopée chinoise risque de
lui resté sur l'estomac
[Musique]
pendant trois jours le français ses
concurrents enchaîne une dizaine
d'épreuves jusqu'au bout de leurs forces
et malgré tous les efforts du
marseillais difficile de rivaliser avec
les jeunes chinois et le champion
suédois
[Musique]
si bien qu'à l'aube du dernier jour il
n'y a pas que le ciel de chengdu ce
qu'ils soient tendres mais le cerveau de
joël aussi et pourtant pour cette
épreuve
ce n'est plus un mais 40 jeux de cartes
que les candidats doivent mémoriser en
seulement une heure un l'idéal est
d'arriver à obtenir 10 paquets joël et
dans les derniers au classement
marvin est toujours en tête mais talonné
de près par ce champion américain alex
müller entre eux tout va se jouer
maintenant
il vous reste une minute après
vérification par les juges
c'est l'américain qui l'emportent au
finish grâce à un incroyable exploit
il a retenu par coeur et dans l'ordre 28
paquet soit 1456 carte
joël lui s'est trompé dès le premier
paquet ça y est c'est fini un peu beauf
la fin de l'après midi c'était c'était
long et ça demandait encore une fois
beaucoup de concentration
si la cité fatiguant sur les cartes
[Applaudissements]
joël termine avant dernier du
championnat c'est l'américain qui
remporte le chèque de trente mille euros
et le titre de maître de la mémoire
marvin termine deuxième
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les chinois eux remporté le premier prix
par équipes
prochain rendez vous pour ces génies de
la mémoire en décembre prochain à
singapour